le saint jérôme de léonard de vinci
c'est d'abord une émotion à l'état pur
ce qui saute aux yeux c'est ce visage
émacié qui esquisse un sourire édenté la
chevelure erreur le dénuement presque
totale et pourtant ce table qui est une
oeuvre inachevée est considéré comme un
chef-d'oeuvre absolu c'est tout ce
processus de lecture du cerveau à
l'intelligence de sama au crayon au
pinceau
au chiffon et même à l'empreinte
digitale puisque il peignait audois donc
tout ça nous est révélée et on comprend
comment léonard construisait ses
chefs-d'oeuvre avec beaucoup de travail
en amont saint jérôme est un mystique
néant vénitie baptisé à l'âge de dix
neuf ans ordonné prêtre à 29 ce docteur
de l'église romaine est le traducteur de
la bible en latin il crée une communauté
dermit et va vivre de nombreuses années
dans le désert immédiatement sur le voir
en voit la souffrance on voit la
souffrance et spirituelle c'est très
intéressant pour la
seulement la vision de l'art et du monde
de léona mais on s'est vraiment pour
cette logique ce tableau est un
véritable coffre-fort ambulants les
mesures de sécurité sont gardées
secrètes pour une oeuvre
inestimable le vatican présente le saint
jérôme dans une vitrine totalement
climatisée avec un système de
climatisation
incorporez l'hygrométrie la température
est vérifié par des capteurs mise à
disposition château du clos lucé pour
une durée de deux mois le saint jérôme
de léonard de vinci pourrait accomplir
des miracles en terme de fréquentation